in the very halls which were the scene
of the alleged crime
those who were its target gathering to
pass judgment on whether the former
president of the united states himself
should bear responsibility the senate
will convene
as a court of impeachment donald trump's
second impeachment trial
itself a moment of american history
beginning with the simple question of
whether congress
has the right to try a former president
at all
what will the january accept what we
expected to be procedural
though quickly became very visceral i'll
show you
and after this we're going to walk down
and i'll be there with you
we're going to walk down we're going to
walk down
to the capitol
[Applause]
senators shown this cinematic retelling
of the events of january the 6th
presented as evidence those seeking to
convict trump
using his words we fight like hell
and if you don't fight like hell you're
not going to have a country anymore and
those of his supporters
together with images of the day
their case is that trump issued a direct
call to the mob
to attack the capital an incitement to
insurrection
for which he must pay if that's not an
impeachable offense
then there is no such thing
it was a powerful reminder of a day that
haunts this country
presidents can't inflame insurrection
in their final weeks and then walk away
like nothing happened but donald trump's
defense is that this trial is
unconstitutional
and that anyway he was only exercising
his right to free speech
this is nothing less than the political
weaponization of the impeachment process
pure raw sport fueled by the misguided
idea of party over country
when in fact both will surely suffer
this trial is almost certain to precede
the same chamber deciding whether donald
trump is guilty
this was a fraudulent election but we
can't
play into the hands of these people
it's unlikely they will convict him but
this is still a moment of reckoning
for an assault on democracy unlike
anything this country has ever seen